a cuba le cortège funèbre en portant les
restes de che guevara quitter la havane
pour parcourir les 300 km qui la
séparent de santa clara où un mausolée a
été dressé à sa mémoire
la population a été invitée à se masser
le long du parcours qui emprunte la
route que che guevara et fidel castro
ont emprunté en 1958 pour entrer
victorieusement dans l'avs
thierry thulliez jean-françois ses jours
de congés exceptionnels à santiago de
las vegas jeunes pionniers ouvriers
paysans sont donc là là c'est le long
d'arbres qui traverse le vieux c'était
le meilleur moyen pour les autorités de
s'assurer du succès populaire de
l'hommage ocz le che justement il est
ici dans toutes les pensées les plus
âgés se souviennent qu'en 1959 la
colonne des guérilleros du commandant
guevara est passée par là dans sa marche
triomphale vers la havane
est à la colombe à 100 l'année passée
par ici en 1959 à aujourd'hui le cortège
fait le chemin inverse pour nous le che
n'est pas mort il a vu comme les enfants
doivent suivre la marche est pour que
nous soyons libres que l'impérialisme
nous laisse tranquille au même moment le
cortège des sept guérilleros tomber en
bout le milliard
la foule ce qui au passage du premier
cercueil celui du che
il ya ni fleurs ni cris seulement le
silence
ça dure quelques secondes le devoir
accompli
la population de se dispersent cela
devrait se passer ainsi tout au long du
parcours de 300 km qui doit conduire le
cortège jusqu'à santa clara une petite
ville au centre de ville où le che ses
compagnons qui sont tombés avec lui en
bolivie seront inhumées vendredi